have you ever bought something nice for
your apartment or your room brought it
home put it in place and had the thought
Jesus my apartment is a piece of [ __ ] or
maybe you bought a new shirt
suddenly you're grabbing for it all the
time waiting for that day and the
rotation when you can wear it again
tired of everything you already own the
name for this social consumerist
phenomena is called the Diderot effect
and it works on two principles first
that all the products purchased by a
consumer aim to be cohesive with that
consumers identity with all the products
that they already own second that the
introduction of a new product which is
desirable but in any way deviant from
the existing cohesion can trigger a
process of spiraling consumption in
other words as much as we decry the
dangers of a materialist society the
things we own comprise a significant
part of who we are our identities are
tied up in our clothes and our gadgets
and the Fung Shui of our furniture more
than anything else we try to find a
unity in our possessions and by
extension try to convince ourselves that
our identity itself is uniform the
effect was first identified by its
namesake French philosopher Denis
Diderot in an essay called regrets on
potting with my own dressing-gown don't
know why I did an English accent there
he's French in the essay Diderot is
given a brand new scarlet dressing-gown
to replace his worn-out one but soon
laments that the luxury of his new item
shames all his other possessions so he
goes on a rampage and replaces
everything he owns with beautiful new
things eventually putting himself in
serious debt I was the absolute master
of my old robe he says I have become the
slave of my new one the Diderot effect
is at the core of the materialist ethos
prodded by that familiar yearning of
keeping up with the Joneses to fit in or
even out class those around us and in
the media we are not capable of stopping
at simply upgrading or updating one
corner of what we own we grab feverishly
at a better kind of unity even at the
expense of our financial well-being this
poses a problem for companies that
produce
goods it's why stuff usually comes in
sets and those sets usually at a
discount it's why IKEA showcases full
rooms in their Disneyland like tour of
the kinds of people you can be can we be
blamed for this materialist craving in
us well the answer is definitely yes but
a soft yes a soft yes for we who are
pampered rats within the capitalist
construct modern men and women laboring
as rust coal says under the illusion of
having a self a cohesive uniform
identity it seems to us might be some
salva gainst the chaotic truth that
reality is as fractious and self
constructed as we are one day we'll have
to strike out against this insane
consumerism
until then the ikea spring living room
set is as good as crack hey everybody
thanks for watching
the Diderot effect is a really
interesting social phenomenon tied in
with a lot of other things you can read
more about it in the links that I'll put
in the description below all companies
that make goods and services deal with
this problem the environmentalist
movement for example is no exception
Green good producers insists not on
buying their stuff but on replacing the
harmful things that you already have
follow me on Twitter I love to tweet and
try to make people think or laugh or
smile or whatever I just think it's an
awesome platform and I'm going to put
this video on reddit and hopefully get
some traction I'll put the link there
when I do and upload it if you enjoyed
this video right it's been awesome in
spreading the stuff that I make and I'll
see you next week